[Music]
hey guys it's me jasmine and i am back
with more tik tok recreations last time
i made a few vegan recipes this time
pasta baby i found two in particular
that i really want to recreate so first
we have the succulent raviolis i'm a
plant mom i saw these and i was like yes
we're doing it second are these lemon
raviolis they look amazing they are
paired with this lemon sauce filled with
a lemon cheese i love lemon anything
let's get started honestly it doesn't
look that hard i'm going to eat my words
later on i
i think i'm losing my mind i'm not going
to lie i'm a little nervous because
danny loves pasta makes it look
extremely easy and
some people think i'm clumsy so we're
gonna start by making the pasta we're
gonna be making two colors and we are
gonna be using all natural ingredients
to color our dough we're gonna start
with 100 grams of flour which is about a
half a cup now i'm gonna add in the
butterfly pt flour we're gonna mix this
together and it is blue but once we add
in the egg you'll see some magic so
we're going to pour this onto our clean
surface
make a little well
add in an egg half a tablespoon of oil
and then continue
mixing and incorporating everything
together egg mixes with the blue from
the butterfly pt flower it's going to
create green
right now it kind of looks like
frankensteiny but it'll all come
together you can totally use the sand
mix if you want to make this a quicker
process but the portions we're making
are quite small so i thought it'd be
easier to do it by hand so after you
roll it all out it's a beautiful
succulent green set it to the side and
i'm going to cover it with a bowl and
then we're going to make our terracotta
pasta it's the same recipe we're gonna
take our flour
and color it this time with paprika mix
it all together
and now we're gonna pour it onto our
surface
use the bowl itself to create a well
add our egg
oh my gosh that's so pretty it's taking
everything in me to not take a picture
but i'll just find it half a tablespoon
of oil i'm just eyeballing it now we're
going to incorporate everything together
the color's already forming it's so
pretty whenever i do make pasta at home
i'll make it with my stand mixer and
i'll make it in large amounts mixing it
all together is a lot more satisfying
feels like i have to you know
put in more love and care into my food
and i like that so same thing with this
we're just gonna knead this until
everything comes together and after you
should have a dough that looks something
like this same thing we're gonna set it
to the side and cover it up with a bowl
so a crust doesn't form on the outside
now it's time for decorating oh my god
i'm really excited oh dang it never mind
it's time to roll it start with a green
dough
i'm going to flatten it with my hands
just a little bit we're going to put it
through our pasta roller
we're looking to get that perfect
rectangle before we actually roll things
out just to make our lives a little
easier i'm gonna do this a couple more
times so it's nice and smooth
oh my gosh it's so beautiful all right
we're gonna do the same thing with our
terracotta dough
beautiful
i see you danny all this hard work for a
short video all right we got both of our
doughs here they look so pretty i'm
scared to touch them danny starts with
this pasta cutter we're gonna press this
but try to avoid the bottom looks good
okay yeah so i'm going to put the
triangle
below
the point of the top to do some window
spacing must be precise
okay the filling is going to go on that
bottom portion there so we want to make
sure we don't cut through that
okay that looks pretty good now we're
going to connect these lines here
i'm scared this is fun though
unless i mess up then it's not fun oh
yes the top layer is good
wow if anyone's gonna do this at home do
not drink caffeine okay cause my hands
are so shaky look at it it looks very
unimpressive right now but that's okay
i'm gonna set this to the side i'm gonna
start doing them
vertically so we can get more succulents
out of it yes
i did each one has taken me about
three minutes when i take the time to
actually make sure it's done well i have
more fun i think that's something you
have to keep in mind even when it's
frustrating so don't take it too
seriously all right i'm gonna do this
last one and then we'll move on to the
terracotta pot all right so what we're
gonna do to create the terracotta pots
i'm gonna cut them vertically about an
inch thick and then a small little thin
strip to create the lip of the pot it's
really hard to keep these moist and when
that crust forms oh doomsday switching
tools
nice so much easier
i'm like holding my hands stable
perfect
one two three four five i can't believe
we made it to this point it is time to
fill our succulents and then assemble
them so i have here a cheese filling it
has parmesan ricotta and egg yolk basil
and garlic i'm a little scared but let's
do this
i think that's good i'm just going to
roll one up first because i want to see
if that filling level is correct we're
going to fold over one side of the leaf
so we can get that window spacing so we
can see all the leaves oh my goodness
i'm obsessed already i'm gonna leave
that first and fill the others before i
roll
i'm just gonna fold it over and then i
will adjust these okay it looks like i
didn't do the window spacing good enough
you know what maybe it'll look better
rolled up
it's so hideous
yes
yes
yes we've done it
we've done it
magic
last one
this one i gave the most space so i'm
gonna add a little more filling
wow i got a hang of it y'all
cute okay so i'm gonna pinch the sides
just to make sure no filling escapes are
you ready
are you ready now what we're going to do
is roll up our succulents the filling is
everywhere oh no
it's kind of cute
brent just went
oh no it's so ugly
hey for epic
they're actually pretty cute i don't
mind the filling there i think once
they're all assembled and standing
together they'll look really good
i'm just hyping myself up you gotta be
your biggest supporter remember that now
for the last one
look at that
biggest takeaway is that you've got to
leave enough space for the filling this
one was the thinnest and this one was
the most space
okay so now that we have that we have
our terra cotta i'm gonna brush this
with a little bit of water it's gonna be
our glue
oh my gosh it's so cute
i love it i'm just gonna fold down the
bottom so there's none
hanging out and i'm gonna take oh it
broke
now i'm going to place this lip and just
line it at the top of the terracotta
plant oh there's a little bit of space
left because i broke it but that's okay
is it cute i have to learn
to not be so hard on myself it's so easy
to criticize and self-criticize but
remember you're just having fun in the
kitchen at the end of the day you're
eating pasta so don't be sad them two
next to each other is really cute
i'm gonna take a little bit of water
just spread the leaves a little bit
rehydrate them okay yeah this is
definitely the cutest one but you know
what these aren't bad like all together
they look very cute it's like my little
garden our pasta's complete it's time to
cook them let's see if all this was
worth it i'm a little worried that
they're not gonna hold its form but
we're just gonna roll with it and i
don't know how long exactly to cook them
for so we'll check them intermittently
oh so cute i can't help it i have to
take a picture smile freddies
and now we wait these are ready oh my
gosh they're so cute
okay so we're gonna take these out oh
i'm surprised they held their shape very
very well honestly i can't believe we
made it this far we are going to do the
sauce we're going to keep it very simple
we're going to add a little bit of
melted butter some salt i'm scared to
get too rough with them i don't want to
mess up the leaves because they're
already a little wilted and sad i'm just
going to plate these i want them all
bunched together because that's what my
garden would probably look like we're
gonna finish this by topping it with
some grated parmesan and here they are
the succulent raviolis i'm hoping the
taste will make it worth it because i
spent a lot of time on these they're not
very pretty i just want them to taste
good now it's finally time to try it
y'all cheers
i like it picasso i really like the
flavors a lot but the ratio is off i
would definitely add more filling but i
can tell it would be good if it was
drenched in more sauce looking at mine
and looking at danny's i wish i didn't
compare them i have to say it ends up
being worth it because i had a good time
making it i think this is a good warm up
let's move on to the next one we're
making a lot of pasta today and it's the
same recipe for the most part so i'm
just gonna show you a bunch of pretty
clips of me making the pasta i won't
bore you with the step-by-step details
yet again
[Music]
the sun has risen birds are chirping and
our dough is finally complete we have
our beautiful white dough that'll be
used for creating the wedges as well as
the pith we have the lighter yellow for
the inside flesh of the lemon the darker
yellow for the outside let's see we
start with the lightest yellow trying to
follow this but it goes so fast so i've
layered my dough i'm gonna do full lemon
slices on this side and as it gets
narrower i'm gonna do half circles to
get wedges my circles look good i feel
like we're gonna get a lot of pasta out
of this one all right let's do a little
bit of cleanup we're gonna shave off the
sides here we got lemons it's time to
fill them we have so many raviolos today
wait no these are ravioli one is raviolo
right no one knows please tell us the
answer five plus five is ten plus four
is fourteen fourteen divided by two is
seven i have seven ravioli and i'm gonna
start by
brushing some water along the edges of
the round okay so i just rewatched the
video i messed up she makes it like
regular ravioli however i cut them all
out first because i'm really good at
directions but that's okay because i was
able to do the calculations to get the
right amount of lemon plus the wedges so
we reduce food scraps i am just using a
lemon whipped burrata here this is the
same one that salty seattle uses
all right
let's press them down i've already put
water on them and just squeeze the
outside oh god
my second one looks great okay so i'm
putting it in the center and i'm
pressing from the filling outwards so
that there are no air bubbles
i would say if you're scared of error
to reduce that margin of error to just
use less filling
but then
you have less filling choose your
character i choose flavor so now we're
gonna make the segments of the lemon
using our white dough i'm just gonna cut
thin white strips and i'm just gonna
keep doing this until i have plenty
brush it with some water okay
so now we're gonna do eight total
segments i wanna make sure it's pressed
down all the way great okay that looks
pretty good i'm just gonna keep doing
this until all of them have their
segments be right back this is gonna
take a while now we have gotten all our
wedges it's time to make the pith the
pith is the white part of the lemon very
bitter so when you're zesting your lemon
you never want to zest the pith okay now
i'm going to do the rest as wedges yes
yes
this is winning people i have all my
circles cut out and to make the pith i
have to use the smaller cookie cutter
place it in the center and cut out the
middle
okay
well
i'm just hoping it'll look cuter later
so i'm gonna continue doing this and
i'll be back for the right
so we got a problem i have the wrong
size cookie cutters and the size i have
would overlap the pith entirely however
if i use one that's too big there's
nothing to glue
onto it so it would just be hanging out
like that that is a no-go so what we're
gonna do is use the same size but we're
gonna wet it with our water glue and
then just kind of situate it in a place
that works best
i have an idea i have an idea
i'm going to roll them out
yeah
can we get a clap sound effect here
oh my gosh
we freaking did it i'm so happy
yay
orange
i'm so proud of this mimo mimo come here
oh my gosh you did it isn't this so cute
yes bye nemo
she's going to sleep now
i'm going to keep doing this and i will
be right back
the evening now in case you're wondering
been waiting for this moment to cut off
these little diggly hoppers that are
popping out of the
orange now okay i'm gonna start with the
wedges these have been taking so long
that when i just press down on it it
crunched oh they're coming apart we're
gonna finish these up and then we'll get
to boiling i think i'm losing my mind a
little bit the tick tocks are like so
short and it took me
all day i can't believe we're at this
point but we are gonna cook it salting
my water first and my water has come to
a boil now i'm just gonna gently place
them in with my hands i'm gonna scoop it
out with a spoon
drain it on my spider
yes everything stayed together i am very
impressed
i'm also quite tired but i'm very
impressed
now that our ravioli's done we're going
to toss in this garlic cream sauce
gonna top it with some peas
some pecorino cheese
oh that looks good
some salt
and some lemon zest
and here we have it lemon ravioli
i would charge 300 for this
more maybe just like my midnight snack
but i'm really excited a lot of tlc went
into this let's give it a try
um
i'm very happy now it was all worth it
in the end so lemony so garlicky so
creamy was it worth it honestly yes it
was worth it because i got to make it i
have a finished beautiful product things
went a little off course however look at
it gorgeous if you guys end up making
any of these pasta shapes make sure to
snap a picture tag me on instagram
because i want to see thanks guys bye
oh yes
let's go to title cards oh yes
[Music]
you